وايضا من دونيتسكو مراسلنا امين
رصدته عفوا من الجانب الروسي بشان ما يدور
على جبهه باخد
نعم سفيان نحن الان في غرب مدينه مخمود
واريد ان اطلب من الزميل المصور ان ينقلنا
سريعا الى المكان الذي سقطت فيه قبل قليل
قذيفه او ربما صاروخ روسي استهدف الاطراف
الغربيه لمدينه مخمود كما تلاحظون ربما
هذه الاعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد من هذه
المنطقه للعلم طبعا يعني منذ قدومنا الى
هنا واصوات القصف لا تكاد تتوقف واضحا
معارك شرسه تدور على جميع محاور مدينه
محمود بالنسبه لقياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
ما زالت تتحدث عن صد الكثير من محاولات
التقدم الروسيه لكن لكن مصادرنا في داخل
المدينه تتحدث عن وضع صعب وخصوصا في
المحور الشمالي للمدينه تعلم سفيان القوات
الروسيه تهاجم من الشمال ومن الشرق ومن
الجنوب هذه الادخنه تتصاعد من المنطقه
الشماليه
والشماليه الغربيه ان صح وصفها لان
محاولات التقدم بشكل كبير من جانب القوات
الروسيه هي من هذا المحور لماذا هي سيطرت
على الطريق الرئيس الطريق السريع
الطريق الجنوبي من الى بخموت وبالتالي
الان القوات الاوكرانيه تستخدم الطريق
الفرعي طريق التفافي عبر القرى يدخل ايضا
من مناطق تقريبا في شمال هذه المدينه الان
القوات الروسيه تحاول استهداف هذا الطريق
هذا القصف في الغالب ويقع على هذا الطريق
الذي يتحدث عنهم والتي تقول اليوم مصرح
للقوات الروسيه وقوات فاجنر بانها استطاعت
ان تقطع هذا الطريق لكن مصادرنا في القوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد بان هذا الطريق مازال
مفتوحا هذا الطريق هو خلفي تماما الان ما
زال يعمل وفي تقدير وتقدير كثير ربما هنا
او القناعه دعني اقول سفيان بانه اذا ما
ادركت القوات الاوكرانيه ان هذا الطريق
سيغلق فان ستنسحب من هذه المدينه لماذا
لان مالات الحرب منذ بدايتها منذ بدايتها
تشير الى هذا الشيء لماذا سيناريو ماريوبل
لم يتكرر فقط في ماريوبل بقيت القوات
الاوكرانيه تدافع حتى اخر رجل
المقاتلون هناك واستسلموا لكن فيما بعد
السيناريو كان مشابه لسيفردونيس مدينه
سيفرودونيس واليس عندما تدرك القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها ستحاصر تنسحب وتعيد في
لعمل دفاعات متقدمه في تلك المدن وتقول
بان هذا افضل للحفاظ على حياه وارواح
الجنود وهو ما قاله الرئيس اكثر من
المناسبه عندما قال باننا لن ندافع عن
مخمود الى اخر رجل لكننا سنبقى فيها قدر
المستطاع وجود القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه
المدينه يدافع عن المنطقه برمتها لماذا
لان القوات الروسيه اذا ما سيطرت عليها
كونها لن تقف عند حدود بخموت وانما ستتقدم
الى مدن مهمه ومهمه جدا في منطقه دونات
واعني هنا طبعا كرامه تورس وسلافياس كبرى
المدن هنا القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تتحدث عن تكبيد خسائر كبيره في صفوف
القوات الروسيه على سبيل المثال بيان
قياده الاركان اليوم تحدث عن وصول 200 جثه
لقوات فاجنر الى مدينه هورلفيكا في دوناس
وان القوات الروسيه قامت بعمل سريع ميداني
لاحصاء هذه الجثث ثم قامت بنقلها دون ان
تسجلها تسجيل الرسمي لهذا ما جاء في بيان
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه لهذا اليوم في
الدلاله على كميه الخسائر الكبيره التي
تتكبدها القوات الروسيه هنا على هذا
المحور والتي تقول هناك ادراك ربما هنا
وهو مقاله ايضا رئيس المخابرات الاوكرانيه
عندما قال تكميد القوات الروسيه هذه
الخسائر سيمنعها من التقدم وشن عمليات
كبيره في محاور اخرى في دون باس وفي غيرها
خسائر يتبدها الروس هذا ما يؤكده الجانب
الاوكراني شكرا لك عامر لافي يذهب الى
دونيتسكو مراسلنا امين درغامي من هناك اخي
الاخبار اذا القادمه دائما من هذه الجبهه
المشتعله جبهه بخموت لكن من الجانب الروسي
هذه المره
الجانب الروسي سفيان يتحدث تقريبا عكس ما
يقوله الجانب الاوكراني الحديث هنا عن اخذ
المبادره في محور ضخمه الشمال الغربي
وايضا هجوم مباغت وسريع نفادته قوات كما
قال احد قادتها اليوم من الجهه الجنوبيه
باتجاه
اخروموفا وهذه البلده اضافه الى بغداد
تقعان على طريق الواصل بين بخموت ومدينه
المجاوره بعد ان كان المستشار رئيس
دونيسكا الموالي لروسيا صباح اليوم قد قال
بان هذين الطريقين باتاه تحت السيطره
الناريه لقوات فاجنر وبالتالي اصبح اصبح
هناك خطر على القوات الاوكرانيه وهذان
الطريقان غير امنان للانسحاب او الدفع
بالدعم اللوجستي لهذه الجبهه من اعدام
اللوجستي الاوكراني وقال بان محاولات
الجان بالدفع بتعزيزات الى المدينه باءت
كلها بالفشل طبعا هذا الحديث يجري بعد
تقريبا ساعات فقط عن تصريح اخر ومثير في
الحقيقه تردد ايضا عن على لسان مستشار
رئيس موالي لروسيا الذي قال بان المعارك
الان باتت تدور داخل وسط مدينه
بخموت اذا كان الحديث هنا عن مركز المدينه
فكل المصادر تتحدث عن ان قوات فيغنر ما
زالت نسبيا بعيده عن مركز المدينه لكن ان
كان الحديث يجري عن نطاق مدينه بخموت وهي
مدينه تقريبا متوسطه الحجم فان القوات
الروسيه متمثله في فاجنر كانت قد دخلت من
الجهه الشرقيه وسيطره على شارع باتريستا
منذ اسابيع وبالتالي وهناك لبس في الحقيقه
وعدم وضوح حتى الان في هذا المعطى الى ذلك
مؤسس شركه فاغنر بريجوجن قال اليوم ان
هناك معلومات استخباراتيه عن استخدام
اعداد من دبابات لبارده الالمانيه الى
الجيش الاوكراني في لكنه اكد في المقابل
على انه لم يتم حتى الان استخدام هذه
الدبابات في معارك باخموت اذا هناك
محاولات لتطويقها المدينه وهذا ما اكد
عليه اليوم ايضا المستشار عفوا رئيس
دانياس دينيس بوشيلي الذي قال بان الاوضاع
باتت مواتيه من اجل احكام الطوق وتضييق
الخناق على الجيش الاوكراني داخل هذه
المدينه طبعا كل هذا يجري بتوازي مع
احتدام المعارك سفيان هنا في دنياسك
تحديدا في جبهه افديفكا المتاخمه لمدينه
دونيسك اصوات القصف المتبادل من الجانبين
لم تهدا منذ ساعات الاولى لصباح اليوم
والسلطات المواليه لروسيا تؤكد وتتحدث عن
استهداف بعض الاحياء السكنيه خاصه في شمال
وفي غرب مدينه دويسك ما ادى الى جرح خمسه
مدنيين حتى الان وفي الحقيقه هذه الاصوات
تصلنا حتى الى مناطق لربما نسبيا بعيدا من
خط الجبهه وتدل على ان المعارك محتدمه في
تلك المنطقه امين ضرغامي شكرا جزيلا